erstes deutsches corona opfer ein 60
jähriger stirbt im ägypten urlaub an dem
neuen virus 16 millionen menschen
isoliert italien regel zur sicherheit
weite teile des nordens ab demos und
appelle am heutigen weltfrauentag
fordern zehntausende rund um den globus
mehr gleichberechtigung
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen beim heute
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag mit mir
im studio für den sport rudi cerne hallo
guten abend aber zunächst zum
grassierenden corona virus das nun auch
ein erstes deutsches todesopfer
gefordert hat einen 60 jährigen der vor
einer woche nach ägypten gereist war und
zwar nach okada am roten meer
zuvor war der mann auch in der stadt
luxor im badeort hurghada war er dann
vorgestern mit fieber in eine klinik
eingeliefert worden erklärte die
zuständige behörde wo er sich angesteckt
hat ist unklar
in ägypten gibt es bislang 48 gemeldete
corona fälle italien greift im kampf
gegen das virus zu immer drastischeren
maßnahmen und schränkt die
bewegungsfreiheit von 16 millionen
norditalienern bis anfang april massiv
ein
betroffen sind die lombardei das
wirtschaftliche herz italiens und damit
auch die metropole mailand für weitere
provinzen sowie für städte wie venedig
gilt ebenfalls keine soll ohne wichtigen
grund rauskommen bislang haben sich in
italien knapp 7400 menschen infiziert
366 sterben kein anderes land in europa
ist stärker betroffen trotz der
gegenmaßnahmen annette hilsenbeck
es ist gespenstisch leer in mailand
heute morgen wo normalerweise das leben
pulsiert auf dem sonst brechend vollen
platz vor dem dom nur wenige menschen
italiens regierung hat große teile des
nordens zur sicherheitszone erklärt
diese gebiete darf nur betreten und
verlassen
wer dringend zur arbeit muss oder andere
wichtige gründe benennt auch innerhalb
der zone soll dies gelten sie den dialog
gibt uns ist klar dass diese maßnahmen
unannehmlichkeiten verursachen und opfer
erfordern manche klein und manche sehr
groß aber in diesen zeiten müssen wir
verantwortung füreinander übernehmen
geschäfte müssen dann wochenende
schließen restaurants sind nur tagsüber
auf zeit nur an beerdigungen sollen
nicht stattfinden spart nur ohne
zuschauer
schulen und universitäten sind bereits
in ganz italien geschlossen
doch weil die zahl der ansteckungen
zuletzt sprunghaft anstieg verschärft
die regierung nun die maßnahmen als die
pläne gestern abend durchsickerten
hasteten menschen zum bahnhof um noch
einen der spezi gericht im süden zu
erwischen stiegen gar ohne fahrkarte in
den zug
heute überwiegt in mailand zustimmung
wir immer noch andere anzustecken also
sollte man die denken wir haben das
erwartet und es ist auch richtig so
fast einen monat bis zum dritten april
gelten die regeln in den
sicherheitszonen erst morgen wenn die
arbeitswoche beginnt wird sich richtig
zeigen wie die sich auswirken
die frage die sich in deutschland viele
stellen warum ist gerade in italien so
viele corona fälle gibt die gebe ich
jetzt gleich mal an andreas postel in
rom weiter andreas gibt es dafür eine
erklärung
ja auch die gesundheitsbehörden in
italien suche nach einer antwort auf
diese frage die plausibelste antwort die
jetzt hier von offizieller seite gegeben
wird ist dass man hier in italien viel
früher begonnen habe mit dem test man
habe patienten untersucht auf den corona
virus und daraus dabei seien besonders
in der lombardei und venetien eben auch
viel mehr positive fälle herausgekommen
die regierung von premierminister konnte
sieht solange sie diese antwort nicht
geben können nur eine möglichkeit weiter
zu versuchen zwei ziele zu erreichen das
eine ist die ausdehnung des corona virus
in italien weiter zu verlangsamen
hinauszuzögern und auf der anderen seite
zu vermeiden dass die krankenhäuser in
italien zu überlasten drohen vielen dank
andreas dass wir uns das ein bisschen
eingeordnet haben jetzt zu den neuesten
fall sein bei uns in deutschland
inzwischen gibt es erste berichte von
rund 1000 infizierten knapp 400 davon in
nordrhein westfalen
und noch eine nachricht lässt aufhorchen
gesundheitsminister sparen empfiehlt
jetzt großveranstaltungen mit mehr als
1000 teilnehmern abzusagen
auch beim koalitionsausschuss der bundes
regierung heute abend ist die korona
epidemie das thema es dürfte wieder mal
kein leichter koalitionsausschuss werden
für die kanzlerin eigentlich sollte es
heute abend um die themen investitionen
und digitalisierung gehen doch die
aktuellen entwicklungen verändern alles
jetzt geht es vor allem um die
flüchtlingskrise und das corona virus
die weitere ausbreitung des virus
verhindern gleichzeitig der wirtschaft
die jetzt schon unter der korona krise
leidet helfen das ist das ziel
steuersenkungen kurzarbeitergeld
schnellerer sowie abbau viele vorschläge
die jedoch noch strittig sind das ist
hilfen geben wird versichert der
wirtschaftsminister gegenüber berlin
direkt die botschaft an all die vielen
mittelständischen unternehmen im messe
und gastronomiebereich ist wir lassen
euch nicht im stich
wir werden euch helfen diese schwere
zeit zu überbrücken zweites großes thema
die situation der flüchtlinge sowohl an
der türkisch-griechischen grenze als
auch in den lagern auf den griechischen
inseln
die spd fordert bis zu 1000 kinder und
jugendliche aus den lagern herauszuholen
ich glaube dass wir nicht nur keine
andere chance haben sondern dass es die
menschlichkeit gebietet dass wir kinder
nicht zu opfern werden lassen in diesem
unsäglichen machtspiel
wir müssen einschreiten wir müssen
helfen die csu und auch teile der cdu
dagegen leben einen deutschen alleingang
ab migration müsse gesteuert werden
wir sollten zusehen dass wir das
zusammen mit unseren europäischen
partnern absprechen und dass wir auch
vor allen dingen vor ort nach
griechenland mehr hilfen hinbringen
denn das sind junge menschen die in
griechenland innerhalb der europäischen
union untergebracht sind viele strittige
themen für die koalition ist dürfte mal
wieder eine lange sitzen werden und wir
bleiben noch beim thema migration der
türkische präsident erdogan hat
griechenland jetzt aufgefordert die
grenzen zu öffnen und flüchtlinge in
andere eu länder weiter ziehen zu lassen
erdogan will morgen in brüssel mit den
spitzen der eu verhandeln
an der türkisch-griechischen grenze gibt
es immer wieder auseinandersetzungen
seitdem die türkei ihre grenzen geöffnet
hat versuchen tausende menschen in die
eu zu gelangen
griechische polizisten gehen dagegen vor
männer sollen sich mehr zeit für die
familie nehmen das fordert
bundeskanzlerin merkel zum heutigen
weltfrauentag gleichberechtigte teilhabe
von frauen im erwerbsleben könne es nur
geben wenn sich auch männer stärker
einbringen sagte sie in ihrem video
podcast auch dafür gingen in berlin
tausende auf die straße außerdem
forderten sie ein ende von sexismus und
gewalt gegen frauen
es war nur eine von vielen
demonstrationen heute weltweit und damit
sind wir schon beim sport und die rudi
turbulenter wintersport wieder an diesem
wochenende zwei podiums plätze gab es
für deutsche starterinnen und starter
beim biathlon weltcup in nove mesto zum
abschluss der wettkämpfe stürmte
franziska preuß im massenstart rennen
auf den dritten platz
ebenso wie im anschluss arnd peiffer wer
springt am höchsten
die siegerin tiere leck auf aus norwegen
oder die drittplatzierte franziska poll
die basis für ihren ersten podestplatz
in diesem winter das gute schiefen bei
20 schuss 19 treffer dazu eine
energieleistung auf der schlussrunde
jack leiden jetzt total das halt endlich
meiner ganz vorn geklappt hat bei den
männern gibt es eine parallele arnd
peiffer ebenfalls nerven stark am
schießstand ebenfalls 19 treffer auf der
strecke verteidigt er mit aller kraft
seinen dritten platz es gewinnt der
norweger johannes büll dahinter im
hirschacker aus frankreich und sichtlich
zufrieden am freitag mit platz drei im
ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga haben die bayern augsburg mit
2 0 geschlagen torschützen thomas müller
und leon goretzka die bayern jetzt mit
vier punkten vorsprung vor dortmund
trotz möglicher geisterspiele um die
ausbreitung des corona virus zu
verhindern sollen die fußball bundesliga
und die zweite liga ihre saison wie
geplant bis mitte mai zu ende spielen
nur so erhalten die vereine trotz
schwieriger umstände planungssicherheit
sagte dfl geschäftsführer christian
seifert und im halbfinale des dfb
vereinspokals wurden folgende
begegnungen gelost rekordpokalsieger
bayern münchen empfängt eintracht
frankfurt viertligist erster fc
saarbrücken trifft auf bayer leverkusen
die spiele finden am 21 und 22 april
statt das willst danke oder bleibt uns
noch das wetter morgen gibt es viele
schauer zwischendurch aber auch einige
wolkenlücken
an den alpen schneit es über 1000 metern
bei zeitweise böiger wind aus west bis
südwest werden 5 bis 12 grad erreicht
der dienstag bringt viel regen an der
nordsee auch sturm ab mittwoch wird das
wetter wieder ruhiger das war es von uns
alle aktuellen entwicklungen auch zum
ersten deutschen corona toten haben wir
auch in einem live blog auf heute de und
natürlich im heute journal mit claus
kleber um 21 45